et tu veux pas avoir des petits frères
et des petites sœurs bah si j'aimerais
bien mais maman peut pas se marier deux
fois tu sais ce que tu vas faire toi
comme métier quand tu seras grande
danseuse étoiles danseuse étoiles tu
fais déjà de la danse oui mais à l'école
à l'école fais voir attends moi aussi
j'en ai fait faites-moi de la danse
classique monsieur pinou
[Musique]
latoua tu connais c'est Philippe Laville
je l'ai vu quoi à la télé ah et comment
tu le trouves pour de vrai bien bien il
est mieux à la télé ou ils sont pareils
ils sont pareils oui tu as passé chaud
tu te marierais avec Philippe Laville
euh il a un petit peu trop grand oui
c'est vrai as bien raison ma puce tu as
bien raison on dirait il deviendra vieux